I spoke last week about the possible
silver lining of the horrific election
of Donald Trump to the White House
Republicans will be controlling the
House of Representatives Republicans
will be controlling the Senate in the
United States and the silver lining
maybe that progressives have been
activated in a real way away I've not
seen for many years under Hillary
Clinton presidency maybe progressives
would have been sort of pacified in
spite of a Republican House and Senate
uh by what would have been a very
centrist Democrat people now are
recognizing you should see my email what
is it stake here record membership sign
ups members and viewers getting in touch
saying David you need to be doing more
corporate media has failed us we cannot
rely on what we got from corporate media
again for the next two four and six
years the show is one thing but we do
need to be doing more and we need to be
actively catalyzing progressives to get
involved in very specific ways so in
addition to what we are now doing and
growing membership in ways to quote job
george w bush like we've never been able
to do so before we will be launching a
major fundraiser soon and we're
finalizing the details but i spent a lot
of the weekend i was thinking of having
the weekend the long weekend to sort of
decompress and relax after the election
but i spent much of the weekend working
with some of our longtime supporters
figuring out the path forward and we are
going to be launching a fundraiser
campaign i don't know exactly when but
it's gonna be soon okay but we are going
to be creating an activism arm of the
david pakman show we've been talking
about progressives need to be
coordinated on what to do at the state
level at the local level republicans are
crushing progressives and this is party
aside but we need to get progressive
candidates elected locally we need to be
able to focus progressives on what steps
can we take now did you know that there
are two gubernatorial elections in 2017
many people emailing me understandably
and saying we've gotta focus on 2018
we've got two opportunities in 2017 that
could prove very important for the 2020
census so there will be more details
soon but we are going to be doing
something major
show is going to obviously continue and
continue to grow but by adding an
activism component and a coordinator for
activating progressives which will then
be disseminated through the show we are
going to be able to redouble or even
more many of our efforts if you want to
be an early donor please get in touch I
know there are lots of people in the
audience who have been emailing saying
David I'm already a member but we've got
to be doing more let me know what it is
that we can do and I'm there well I'm
letting you know right now if you have
premium ideas for this fundraiser if you
want anything that you want to get you
have such stuff you want to communicate
to me about what the goals of this
fundraiser should be in the best ways to
leverage the 200 station national
presence that we've built plus YouTube
and directv dish network the podcast
etcetera let me know it became very
clear over the weekend that people want
to be involved get in touch more soon
and in the meantime please continue to
sign up for membership in the record
numbers that you have we've got the 2017
calendars available at david pakman.com
slash calendar 17 and uh you can use the
coupon this is blowing up I voted 17 all
one word I voted 17 you pick any
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership i voted 17 gives you a forty
percent discount off of your membership
i want you involved at any price
anything that you're saying here's my
three bucks a month if six is not
affordable uh all of this is going to be
huge going forward and more on that very
very soon